Netflix is a genuine treasure trove
when it comes to movies — and many
of the platform's original productions are
counted among the most exciting releases of
the last few years. Here's a look at the
10 most-watched Netflix original movies,
ranked according to their
ratings on Rotten Tomatoes.
In 2019, a stunning 83 million viewers tuned
in to watch Michael Bay's streaming debut;
6 Underground. The film's Rotten Tomatoes
stands at 36%, but critics weren't really the
intended audience to begin with. And the score
actually places it squarely in the middle of
Bay's filmography, review-wise. So if you're a
fan of the director's trademark frenetic action
stylings, this will be right up your
alley. It's a crowd pleaser, to be sure.
The plot centers on an elite group of
mercenaries who have faked their own deaths
in order to carry out missions off the grid.
Their assignment: travel to the fictional land
of Turgistan to replace the country's
brutal dictator with his imprisoned brother.
With its loud explosions,
snappy action-movie dialogue,
and an unrelenting pace, 6 Underground is without
a doubt a prime cut Michael Bay production — and
if that sounds like your kind of thing, then
you're bound to find it a whole heap of fun.
Hollywood power partners Mark Wahlberg and
director Peter Berg have produced a number
of great movies — including Lone Survivor,
Deepwater Horizon, and Patriots Day. Sadly,
Spenser Confidential didn't quite earn
the same rave reviews as those pictures.
A 37% Rotten Tomatoes score didn't stop 85 million
people from streaming this throwback cop movie,
making it one of the platform's biggest ever hits.
The movie is an adaptation of Robert B.
Parker's popular Spenser novels, with Wahlberg
stepping into the famous detective's shoes.
Spenser is a cop who plays by his own rules,
which doesn't play so well at a time when
police brutality is under heightened scrutiny.
The script is co-written by Oscar-winner Brian
Helgeland, and it gives Wahlberg plenty of
excuses to kick ass with his partner and cut
it up with his wise-cracking buddy. Meanwhile,
a number of amusing cameos by famous faces
help liven things up between all the action.
Since it's based on just one
book in the Spenser series,
and considering the huge number of people
who watched it, it's hard to imagine
Wahlberg won't holster up for a sequel
as the famous detective sometime soon.
In 2014, Adam Sandler's Happy Madison Productions
signed a lucrative deal with Netflix that
has since produced some of the comedian's most
widely viewed films. The most-watched among them,
Murder Mystery, brought in 83 million
viewers, which in box office terms would
make it a financial success on par with The
Waterboy. It also earned pretty good reviews,
relative to most Sandler comedies,
earning a 44% score on Rotten Tomatoes.
The film reunites Sandler with his Just
Go With It co-star Jennifer Aniston,
and it allows the Sandman to vacation in
exotic locales with his best buds for the
cause of comedy. The movie's script is sharp
and sprightly enough to keep everyone else as
entertained as the people who made it.
The premise: Sandler and Aniston are a
couple traveling through Europe on their
15th wedding anniversary. On the plane,
they meet a mysterious billionaire who
invites them to party on his yacht with
his elderly uncle. While at sea, however,
the uncle is found killed with his own dagger —
and Sandler and Aniston are the main suspects.
"Audrey."
"Yep."
"Get the cocktail sauce."
Released the same year as Sandler's
critically acclaimed Uncut Gems,
Murder Mystery finds the actor in the familiarly
goofy territory lots of fans want to see
from the funnyman. For that reason alone, it's
perhaps no mystery why so many people tuned in.
George Clooney's sci-fi epic
The Midnight Sky earned a 50%
Rotten Tomatoes score. Critics noticed that the
movie has more than a few things going for it,
bringing in 72 million viewers and earning
an Oscar nomination for its visual effects.
Clooney stars as Augustine, a dying
scientist stranded on an Earth that
has been ravaged by an unseen disaster. Left
alone at a research facility in the Arctic,
he attempts to warn off any spaceships on
their way back to the desolated planet.
When he finds himself unable to reach the incoming
crew of the "Aether," Augustine travels across the
frozen tundra to warn them — but the ship's
crew are having a few problems of their own.
The two halves of The Midnight Sky really come
together in a third-act twist that links an
emotional through-line between
them. Along with the story,
the technical aspects of the
film are unarguably stunning,
from Martin Ruhe's cinematography to
Alexandre Desplat's heartbreaking score.
As the summer of 2020 dragged on, it
became increasingly clear that the
pandemic would keep theaters closed.
So naturally audiences increasingly
turned to streaming services to get their
blockbuster kicks. It's little wonder, then,
that 75 million people watched the high-concept
action thriller Project Power when it dropped
on Netflix that August. The movie also
netted a 61% Rotten Tomatoes rating.
In an era dominated by
mainstream comic book movies,
Project Power imagines a stranger scenario —
one in which anyone can become a superhero by
taking an experimental drug. The catch:
the effects only last for five minutes,
and there's no telling what superpower you might
gain… or whether you'll use it for good or evil.
Chaos predictably ensues when the
drug hits the streets of New Orleans,
so teenager Robin teams up with a local
cop and an ex-soldier to track down the
evil pharmaceutical company who made
it. As the critics will tell you,
the true power of this film comes from its
impressive performances and thrilling action
sequences. And there's still plenty of room to
add more to the intriguing story in a sequel.
It seems like only yesterday that the Bird
Box challenge was sweeping the nation,
forcing Netflix to issue a public plea for
people to stop walking around while blindfolded.
Released during the holiday season of
2018, this movie does for sight what
A Quiet Place did for sound. And just like
that horror hit, Bird Box was a sensation,
bringing in a total of 89 million
viewers and a 63% Rotten Tomatoes score.
Adapted from the novel by Josh Malerman,
the movie stars Sandra Bullock as Malorie,
an expectant mother whose fears of becoming
a parent are quickly set aside for an even
greater terror. To reveal much more would
spoil the movie's fascinating premise,
but it's probably fair to say that the scene in
which Malorie and her children make their way
through the woods is among the most iconic
horror sequences of the last few years.
Susanne Bier creates a constant
sense of dread and tension
throughout Bird Box, relying on good
old-fashioned suspense and atmosphere
over flashy special effects. She also
does a good job with her ensemble,
eliciting performances that keep you invested
in the human story at the heart of it all.
With 99 million viewers, Extraction is the
most-watched film in Netflix's history,
and there's certainly a good reason for that:
the film hit the streaming site in April 2020,
just as the coronavirus pandemic was forcing the
closure of movie theaters across the country.
The movie earned a 67% approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes,
and the high viewership was more than enough to
justify a sequel — and perhaps even a franchise.
Directed by Sam Hargrave from a script by Joe
Russo, Extraction has got all the trappings of
a whiz-bang action blockbuster. Chris Hemsworth
stars as Tyler Rake, a mercenary tasked with
rescuing the son of an imprisoned Indian crime
lord who's been kidnapped by his father's rivals.
Extraction's action is its best quality,
being masterfully directed by Hargrave,
who had previously worked as a stunt
coordinator on Hemsworth's various
Marvel Cinematic Universe films. He also
makes the most out of the film's R rating,
spilling blood by the bucketful and bringing a
real intensity to the film's action sequences.
What more could you want from
a punchy lockdown blockbuster?
Zack Snyder dominated the streaming services
in early 2021. Shortly after his four-hour
director's cut of Justice League hit HBO Max,
the director released the grisly horror flick
Army of the Dead on Netflix. It didn't take long
for Army of the Dead to crack the streamer's Top
10 most viewed films, racking in a staggering
72 million viewers. Plus, the movie's 68%
Rotten Tomatoes score places it in the top half of
Snyder's filmography from a critical standpoint.
Considering Snyder's first film was a remake
of George A. Romero's Dawn of the Dead,
it's only fitting that he would one day return to
the zombie genre. Army of the Dead is a sly hybrid
of horror and heist movies, following a mercenary
who is tasked with recovering $200 million from
a casino vault in a zombie-infested Las Vegas,
before the military nukes the city off the map.
Snyder seems to paint the
screen with blood in this movie,
making the most of his hard-R rating. The
supporting cast helps liven things up, too,
most notably Tig Notaro as one of lead
actor Dave Bautista's gang of thieves.
"Hundred percent, I'm in."
"You don't want to know the risks, or…"
"Why would I want to know the risks?"
For fans of Snyder and his flashy,
stylized type of movie, it really
doesn't get much better than this.
One of the surprise hits of the
pandemic summer was The Old Guard,
which hit Netflix in July 2020. All
in all, 78 million viewers tuned in,
with interest undoubtedly piqued by the
movie's sterling 80% score on Rotten Tomatoes.
Charlize Theron stars as Andy, the immortal
leader of an elite squad of mercenaries.
Together with her brothers-in-arms, Andy
travels the globe protecting mortals — and,
along the way, picks up a soldier who
discovers that she too is unable to die.
In adapting writer Greg Rucka and artist
Leandro Fernandez's graphic novel,
director Gina Prince-Bythewood infuses the
superhero genre with the sublime passions
of her previous films. What's really special about
The Old Guard is the way in which Prince-Bythewood
so deftly balances the movie's more
emotional scenes with its action sequences.
Those elements work in perfect harmony
with Theron, who brings plenty of emotional
heft to her performance — and once again
proves herself to be an apt action star.
At a time when Marvel and DC have taken
great pains to create interconnected sagas
geared towards mass consumption, The Old
Guard is proof that an original vision
can break through — and find
a mass audience to boot.
The Netflix smash hit Enola Holmes raked
in 76 million viewers during the fall
of 2020. It's also one of the platform's
most critically acclaimed titles,
with a certified fresh 91% Rotten Tomatoes rating.
Millie Bobby Brown plays Enola Holmes, a
teenage sleuth who's following in the footsteps
of her famous older sibling, Sherlock. While
Sherlock is happy to encourage her sleuthing,
her other brother, Mycroft, thinks she'd be better
placed learning etiquette at finishing school.
"I don't want a husband!"
"And that is another thing you
need to have educated out of you."
When her mother goes missing, however,
it's up to Enola to track her down,
deciphering clues from a variety of
birthday presents she left behind.
Her investigation uncovers a vast conspiracy
revolving around a young aristocrat,
who's similarly trying to break free of
the societal restraints placed upon him.
It's not difficult to see why this was such a hit.
Enola Holmes is just dangerous and droll enough to
have some real edge, while providing teenage
viewers with an uplifting girl-power message.
Considering it's based on just one book from
Nancy Springer's popular Young Adult series,
it's also safe to say the adventures
of Enola Holmes are far from finished.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.